Spain was since the discovery of the new
world at the forefront of European
politics under Charles the first and
philippe ii spain was the cultural
military and economic master of the
western world its Empire stretched from
California to Cape Horn and the immense
riches of the Americas flowed back to
Madrid Spain's Habsburg rulers alongside
their relatives who run the Holy Roman
Empire dictated European politics for
centuries yet this came to an end in
Spain was replaced as a global power by
the Dutch the French in English the
question is why did this happen and when
was this process complete at what point
did Spain the conquerors of a continent
lose the title of Europe's greatest
power and furthermore when did it stop
being a great power all together it was
under Charles the first and Philippe the
second that Spain's power in Europe was
at its height yet it was during the
later reign of Philippe the second that
things started to sour the Spanish
monarch was also known as the Catholic
monarch and was dedicated to preserving
and protecting the church two things on
this front for Spain's attention first
was the Muslim Ottoman Empire to the
south whom Spain wanted to keep out of
Europe and this culminated in the 1571
Battle of Lepanto which tippity Valley
was expensive
the second challenge to it was the
Protestant Reformation which sold the
Netherlands rebel against Spain and also
brought Philippe's kingdom into conflict
with the English all of these things
were quite expensive not least the
failure of the Spanish Armada which
basically bankrupted Spain however
Phillipe did manage to inherit Portugal
and its empire - which gave Spain a
major boost philippe ii died in 1598 and
was succeeded by his son philippe the
third who would in 1618 bring spain into
the thirty years war against the
protestant powers of Europe and France
Spain actually performed quite well
during the war but he was extremely
costly also revolts broke out in
Portugal and Catalonia which are Philip
the fourth in 1640 effectively lose
control of the former in 1648 at the end
of the war Spain acknowledged Dutch
independence and thus lost access to the
richest lands in Europe and also now had
to deal with another rival at sea in
1658 Spain was defeated by France which
effectively established louis xiv as
Europe's leading mark and also saw Spain
lose this land it's at this point we can
safely say that Spain was no longer the
foremost power of Europe Spain suffered
more difficulties when the heavily
disabled an airless charles ii died in
1700 he had nominated Phillipe of Anjou
the grandson of louis xiv
as his heir this was unacceptable to
many of Europe's powers because it made
Spain a permanent ally of France and so
war they spoiled the war of the Spanish
Succession
ended with Filipe taking up the throne
on the condition that Spain in France
never unite and also that's been give
all of these territories to the Austrian
Hapsburgs and despite all of this Spain
was still a great power just a
diminished one in the century following
the war of succession the Spanish sought
to reform their Kingdom and the Empire
with it these reforms were especially
pronounced during the reign of Charles
the 3rd who opened the Empire strayed to
other nations had introduced a much more
direct form of governance it was Charles
the 3rd son Charles the 4th whose
actions meant Spain would lose its
status as a great power he sided with
Napoleon during the Napoleonic Wars but
was himself ousted from power in 1808
and succeeded by his son Ferdinand the
7th Napoleon wasn't okay with Ferdinand
and so wanted his brother Joseph
Napoleon made Spanish King civil war
broke out Napoleon invaded Joseph was
made King and France pinched Catalonia
revolts against King Joseph broke out
across Spanish America and even after
Napoleon had been defeated and Ferdinand
restored those who lived there felt that
Spain could no longer provide wealth and
security Spain was essentially sidelined
after the Napoleonic Wars in the decades
following lost most of her American
colonies to revolution this was followed
by yet more decades at near constant
civil strife and conflict within Spain
itself it was thus at this point after
the Napoleonic Wars that Spain was no
longer considered a great power but
thereafter remain on the sidelines of
European politics I hope you enjoyed
this episode and thank you for watching
with extra thanks to my patrons that you
see on screen now and a special thanks
to James Bissonnette David archaeologist
Zarqa flash Party Boyko Rob Waterhouse
Yasha Enderman Chris wicker Myles Bailey
Brent Gard Michael Reynolds Gustav Swan
tun Rick Onion duck Maggie pax Kowski
Winston k-word phacelia Ravidas
Anthony Beckett Adam Harvey Ike Skye
Chappelle and the amusement park Ives